lo que vamos a intentar hacer en este
vídeo es tomar la integral de superficie
a lo largo de ésta
digamos superficie sigma de la función x
cuadrada ok y vamos a tomar una
superficie muy particular
digamos que nuestra superficie sigma va
a ser la esfera unitaria esto es
aquellos puntos del espacio que cumplen
que x cuadrada más ye cuadrada maceta
cuadrada es igual a 1 estos son la ex
feria la esfera unitaria y lo que vamos
a enfocarnos en en este primer vídeo es
en parametrizar esto porque nos llevará
varios vídeos llegará a calcular y esta
integral va a llevarnos varios vídeos
por ahora sólo vamos a parametrizar esta
superficie y que generalmente es la
parte más difícil sobre todo para
visualizar cómo es que estamos moviendo
nuestros parámetros y demás el resto
puede ser incluso mecánico y quizás
hasta engorroso pero bueno ahorita vamos
a concentrarnos solo
entonces vamos a pensar primero que
ocurre en o vamos a pensar que estamos
viendo digamos el espacio
me lo pintó mejor digamos que este es
nuestro eje z y que estamos viéndolo
desde una perspectiva que simplemente el
plano lo vemos en una línea imagínense
que que están viéndolo de esta forma
sale es es una perspectiva un poco rara
quizás pero bueno aquí lo que quiero ver
es que si tenemos nuestra nuestra esfera
unitaria digamos
más o menos es de ladito ching se ve
algo así pero espero cache muy bien lo
que es mi dibujo de la esfera
ok digamos que esta es la esfera sale
entonces este de aquí va a ser el plano
xy
este de aquí y por supuesto este de acá
arriba es nuestro eje z entonces para
que se vea que realmente estoy pintando
una esfera de gm le doy este un poco de
borde de brillo
esta es mi esfera entonces vamos a
intentar parametrizar la estamos
viéndolo de lado y podemos fijarnos que
podemos tener aquí en cualquier en
cualquier línea que tomemos del centro a
un punto de la de la esfera pues vamos a
tener radio uno correcto porque eso es
parte de la definición de la esfera
unitaria entonces donde intersecta
pensemos en donde intersectan toda esta
esfera
en el plano xy y en realidad intersecta
en esta parte que estoy pintando con con
con magenta correcto entonces como
veríamos esta parte de la intersección
ya en el plano xy entonces ahora vámonos
al plano xy
este es nuestro eje y y este es nuestro
eje x y este es el eje x y este es el
eje y que es lo que estamos viendo la
intersección de esta esfera con el plano
xy esencialmente nos da un círculo
verdad y es un círculo de radio 1
déjenme ver si alcanzo a pintarlo bien
más o menos creo que me quedo mucho
mejor que el de la esfera ahí está este
es nuestro círculo unitario porque es
unitario porque si nos tomamos cualquier
radio cualquier radio sobre este círculo
en realidad tenemos que esto tiene radio
1 verdad de hecho sabemos muy bien
cuáles son las coordenadas de este punto
porque eso nos va a recordar muchísimo
lo que son las coordenadas polares
tenemos que esto es coseno de un
parámetro que voy a introducir aquí que
se va a llamar ese entonces es coseno de
ese seno de ese y como no tenemos altura
pues en nuestra tercera coordenada va a
tener cero
ok aquí podemos estar pensando que el
eje z pues está apuntando directamente
hacia ti digamos como que se sale de la
pantalla y apunta hacia ti ok entonces
ya que tenemos esta intersección podemos
empezar a pensar cómo parametrizar
cualquier punto de la de la de la esfera
verdad vamos a regresar nos ahora a ésta
a esta digamos a este diagrama y voy a
introducir aquí un parámetro t que
esencialmente el parámetro t me está
diciendo que tanto estamos rotando hacia
arriba o hacia abajo respecto al plano
xy correcto por ejemplo si yo tuviera un
radio digamos por acá abajo pues estamos
viendo que tanto se está elevando pero
en sentido contrario ok
eso es más o menos lo que me mide
nuestro parámetro t entonces simplemente
vamos a utilizar un poquito de
trigonometría para pensar bueno qué tal
que yo tuviera un punto aquí y entonces
yo corto con un plano digamos paralelo
al plano xy
aquí está digamos un plano
y estamos cortando a esta esfera con
este nuevo plano entonces cuando
cortamos esta esfera con el nuevo plano
pues tenemos una nueva circunferencia de
intersección es decir la parte donde se
intersecta simplemente es esto entonces
la pregunta es bueno aquí vamos a
interceptar una esfera piensa en una
esfera y que las rebanadas digamos con
un cuchillo pero no por la mitad sino
más arriba entonces lo que uno ve es
como una tapa circular estarás de
acuerdo la pregunta es bueno y ese
círculo que radio tiene ok aquí por
ejemplo cuando interpretamos con el
plano xy tenía un radio uno pero aquí no
va a tener un radio no es un radio más
pequeño entonces cómo podemos ver esto
bueno simplemente fijémonos que de aquí
del eje z alto a este primer punto de
intersección es exactamente la misma
distancia que está que tenemos aquí pero
está que tenemos aquí por simple
trigonometría es coseno de t entonces
pensemos que si interpretamos con un
plano
digamos de esta a esta altura de la
esfera en realidad vamos a tener una
circunferencia mucho más pequeña de gm
más arriba digamos vamos a tener una
circunferencia más pequeña
más o menos de esta forma
ahí está un poquito
pasado de este lado pero ya está
corregido entonces
este que radio va a tener bueno va a
tener el mismo la misma distancia que de
aquí del centro de digamos dónde
intersecta el eje z y el plano xy a este
punto donde es el pie de la altura de
este triángulo formado por el ángulo t
ok entonces este por simple
trigonometría pues tiene radio coseno de
t es decir si yo tengo aquí mi radio
éste tiene radio coseno de t ok entonces
recordemos otra vez quiénes son las
coordenadas polares entonces este punto
de aquí este punto de aquí simplemente
va a tener tres coordenadas correcto
este punto de aquí lo estoy pensando
como que es este mismo
aquí por ejemplo nuestro ángulo s pues
estará variando mucho más verdad
entonces pensemos ahora si qué
coordenadas tiene esto bueno recordemos
que cuando tenemos coordenadas polares
es justamente esta expresión
multiplicada por el radio entonces el
radio es coseno de t por lo tanto
entonces irlo escribiendo que este punto
tiene radio coseno de t por el coseno de
s si simplemente es esta expresión y
multiplicarla por el radio y éste tiene
radio coseno de t ahora la segunda
coordenada pues va a ser el radio coseno
de t por seno de s
muy bien y ahora la altura la altura
simplemente consideremos ahora en este
diagrama que si aquí tenemos t entonces
nuestra altura va a estar determinada de
esta forma por esta digamos por esta
línea pero si esto es coseno de t la
altura quien es pues será simplemente
seno de t ok entonces la altura en este
caso va a ser seno
dt muy bien y este es nuestro punto
sobre la esfera donde s pues pensemos en
entre qué valores se pueden mover el
parámetro s y entre qué valores se puede
mover el parámetro t entonces ese como
vimos pues puedes es el ángulo sobre el
plano xy entonces puede estar entre 0
y 2
ok es decir podemos movernos digamos
desde aquí e ir dando toda la vuelta
toda la vuelta hasta dar una sola para
no repetir más correcto ahora pensemos
en el ángulo t porque en el ángulo t
aquí podemos estamos digamos tomemos
como como base el plano xy y podemos
movernos hacia abajo o hacia arriba
entonces si nos movemos hacia abajo a lo
más que nos podemos mover es un cuarto
de vuelta estarán de acuerdo y un cuarto
de vuelta no es otra cosa más que pi
medios pero como nos movemos hacia abajo
en realidad es negativo entonces este a
lomé al menos puede ser menos y medios y
ahora si nos empezamos a elevar pues a
lo más podemos elevarnos un cuarto de
vuelta es decir elevarnos y medios un
ángulo de pi medios entonces aquí ya
están determinados los dos valores
o más bien el rango de valores posibles
para los dos parámetros y simplemente
podemos escribir ya esto de forma
los vectorial o con una función porque
el punto de la esfera de que depende de
ese y de t simplemente será en su
primera coordenada coseno de té por
coseno de s que multiplica al vector y
es decir esto es la primera la primera
entrada a la primera coordenada más
con seno de t seno de s
seno de s y esto en la dirección j es
decir en la segunda entrada y finalmente
vamos a tener que agregar el seno de t
seno de t que multiplica al vector
unitario acá y esta es nuestra
parametrización nuestra función
vectorial que depende de dos parámetros
y ya hemos acabado estas son estos son
los rangos estos de aquí en los que se
están en los que están definidos los
parámetros así que este es el primer
paso para matizarlas superficie y ahora
vamos a calcular la integral de
superficie que incluye calcular por ahí
un producto cruz que se puede volver un
poquito engorroso o medio peludo y
después evaluaremos la integral por sí
misma